[Musique]
salut les je rappelle pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent que la chasse à la perdrix ou
venant de jours il est d après lui c'est
[Applaudissements]
toujours chasseurs mais dans sa soeur
j'ai dit je me dis quoi je commence avec
une vanne sur les cheveux ont fait une
bonne chronique et je ne me permettrais
pas tué mais c'est pas pareil c'est un
accident capillaire tu as tu connaîtras
c'est un jour j'espère cacao bois la
langue alors là c'est le camembert qui
dure encore mais bon elles bonnes bases
et menace d'un carambolage c'est une
bague qui fait un carton à la sécurité
routière
[Rires]
qu'est ce qu'un soutien parmi les voilà
l'ambition est là et là on est sur rtl a
pris 2 sont sans faille et une vague là
on est sur rtl rtl
j'ai connu le jingle maintenant tu as un
talent un teint hâlé tout de suite une
nouveauté est tout de suite une
nouveauté bien entendu les lacs du
connemara aller après on retrouvera le
jeune de la station qui a 55 ans bruno
guillon
[Applaudissements]
trouver le bout balle rdr c'était
l'amour est dans le pré sur m6 et j'ai
regardé mais avec une technique un peu
particulière j'avais un oeil sur la télé
l'autre oeil sur twitter non mais alors
exactement c'est le top 3 twitter et il
arrive avec des nouveaux on y va aller
au numéro 3 on à eric le gentleman
anglaise tout en élégance et en
délicatesse voilà eric berry keryx
eclaron la finesse et la classe incarnée
dit tu mets ta gueule madame numéro 2 on
retrouve jean claude qui a déjà ses fans
inconditionnels [ __ ] quelle bouillie
me dégoûte les jean-claude 63 ans bélier
ascendant gros lourds dingues de
paisiello n'y paraît d'enfants il ya des
bonnes siestes avec les familles et au
numéro un on à didier le cousin de jean
michel maire qui a un peu de mal avec
les mots sonnent et aussi avec les
bananes
didier vous pensez vraiment qu'elle ne
comprendrait fait semblant en tout cas
didier a parfaitement résumé limousine
d'abord ce match on adore ce bec avec
skoda d'autres moments tendresse on a vu
une famille toute mignonne faire une
balade à vélo dans famille
extraordinaire sur six ter ah oui j'aime
bien ça cette famille nombreuse fait une
balade à vélo c'est comme un peloton qui
se déplacent comme ils sont mignons
quoi qu'est ce qu'elle a dit ah si
seulement quelqu'un a entendu ce qu'elle
a dit la dame
[Musique]
le petit coup à la dame
[Applaudissements]
je souhaitais les antennes et moi bombe
arthur n'oublions et jean luc reichmann
chez pascal praud j'adore pascal et
patrick sébastien parce que c'est ma
passion pas celle où je l'adoré les sur
ces news et l'oci à la radio sur rtl
sauf que son émission radio elle est
filmée et mon petit doigt me dit que
pascal où elle avait oublié ce petit
détail 14 heures et 14 heures
les éditeurs on a besoin pascal praud
sur les tv confier directement on peut
faire la mise en place les marquages au
sol il combine willy donc on s'est passé
un peu au départ parce que tu as comme
millions plus donc j'ai pas mangé donc
ces quatre créateurs donc famille
nouveau de tutos n importe comment donc
le vrai problème est de donner la parole
à tout le monde ou pas mais puiser le
roi des baux pillards alors je voudrais
dire ça ses propres atouts légendaires
tels isabelle isabelle vous le savez est
long et son doigt là on va chercher la
pole avec un pot de miel entier
c'est vrai que vous aussi vous à vous le
faites aussi c'est plus un stylo que
maintenant ah ouais mais pas très bien
mais j'aimerais pas être la personne qui
le prend dans la bouche après
heureusement qu'eric notre avis c'est
comme ça que je me suis cramé le tympan
j'ai vomi que j'avais mis un stylo j'ai
tout ça et c'est là que vous avez une
vie trépidante
j'adore quand on met pas en arrière
mathieu on va faire plaisir à rosny tout
de suite puisque vous allez des
marseillais qui aime bien châtie bien
c'est vrai qu'il m'arrive de charrier un
peu sur des fautes de grammaire
sauf que là c'est carrément un test de
culture générale attention c'est une
boucherie
après c'est pas des questions faciles
facile alors on se moque pas on se doit
crapa commence avec la première question
c'était moi toutes les voyelles
c'était moi le plus d'adjectifs
qualificatif possible chacun bretons y
est le verbe aller au futur carnot je
vais tu vas il va nous allons vous allez
il pour terminer
chaque jour on repousse les limites là
les chéris là on a un extrait avec lui
dit vous allez voir vous êtes dans une
chaîne avec jean attend les jeunes
génies de suite regardé
ne manquez pas cynique et regarde
exactement hier c'était à prendre ou à
laisser
vous savez quand même que c'est un jeu
qui est basée sur le suspense mais il
laisse deux boîtes aux jumeaux attention
à une à 5 euros
une à trois milieux suspense est à son
comble à l'intention est intenable mais
on avait oublié de choses bah c'est
qu'on est sur ces 8es ray est du coup
petit problème au moment de l'ouverture
de la boîte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on habite jean pierre timbaud tu m'as
envoyé à m'échapper moi je ne savais pas
le stade en tête c'est jean pierre qui
me l'a dit prophète qui a gardé les
bijoux gagner sans quoi pierre et on ya
partie satimo termine avec quoi le
zapping et c'est pas parce que tu es
droit de la chasse qui suit tu dois
faire le bonheur c'est au 1 c'est bon
hélas zapping et le zapping matin la
mère l'otan mais toujours a fait halte
en maintenant bas on va pas le faire
c'est parti ça fait grâce aux douze
coups de midi on en a appris un peu plus
sur les six styles et sadi a
immédiatement suivi des secteurs les bee
gees dîner presque parfait la philosophe
kim glow découvre proust sans traîner
ses vacances à introd teintées non c'est
mon choix evelyne thomas est toujours
aussi sympa avec ses invités rage osef
ahmadi dont vous êtes sapé comme votre
chienne à roland garros pour djokovic
tout va bien mais qu'on lui et quand on
a envoyé spécial on peut être
journaliste sur ses news
sur france 3 avoir touché le sud de la
bretagne vous l'avez vu dans le
reportage à bien s'il est journaliste
sur tf1 mais vous avez bien compris
l'actualité du jour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]